[Music]
hi my name is sandrine huzan and i'm the
stranding and rehabilitation manager for
the sea otter program at the monterey
bay aquarium
come on in and take a sneak peek the
outer care program at the monterey bay
aquarium takes in
stranded injured and orphaned sea otters
to be rehabilitated and released back
into the wild so we actually spend the
majority of the time
observing these otters in this office
using our camera systems and
monitors this is a great tool for us to
be able to observe them
without directly impacting their
behavior these are the current otters
that we have in-house
and as you can tell the majority of them
have numbers for names
and this is so that we don't become
attached to these otters that are going
to be released back into the wild
ivy is one of our resident otters and
she acts as a surrogate for
our orphan pups like all wild animals
it's important for the public to give
them their distance
injured and orphaned otters can be very
dangerous and can fight
they can easily transmit diseases to
humans as well which is why it's
important to
keep your distance and allow for experts
to handle them
paul is prepping some food and what do
we got
we are currently from the squid
this is definitely one of their least
favorite items but it's good for them to
have a variety
sea otters at the monterey bay aquarium
eat very well it is important that they
have a diverse diet
providing proper enrichment is really
important for all
age groups that are under our care but
specifically for pups this gives them
the opportunity to practice manipulating
objects which then
translates to being able to handle live
prey as they get older taking care of
pops is a full-time job
they get offered formula approximately
every three to four hours
and once they get older and have the
appropriate dentition
we then start offering solid food
eventually we get them to the point
that they can recover food and dive to
the bottom on their own
before going in with a surrogate one of
our primary goals when working with
these dependent pups
is ensuring their successful release
back in the wild and one of the ways
that we can do that
is by helping to prevent imprinting and
habituation on humans we want to make
sure
that they don't associate anything
positive with humans such as food
or grooming in order to do that we need
to disguise ourselves
to create a shapeless form that hides
the human body
so since this heart is going to be
released back into the wild
i want to make sure to disguise myself
properly so that she's not associating
anything positive with humans
and warm formula is definitely something
positive
so i'm going to be wearing this disguise
first this
then a mask cover my face which i'll
have down once i'm in with her
and then i also want a way of protecting
my arms because
like we talked about these otters have
sharp teeth
once a pup has been weaned from their
surrogate they will spend more time in a
tank
with different companion animals working
on socialization
continuing to learn how to forage
independently and
at the point in which we see that they
are consistent in their behavior
body condition looks good code condition
looks good and around
nine to ten months is really the time
when we would start considering
releasing
given that we've spent so much time
working with these otters and
rehabilitating them
and having gone through the surrogacy
program we want to make sure that
there's a way that we can track them
and monitor their progress once they're
released back into the wild so before
they go
they are outfitted with some of these
accessories the first thing that they
get
is a radio transmitter that is
surgically implanted in their abdomen
and this transmitter will be able to
emit a signal
every time they're at the surface of the
water and if we have an antenna
and a receiver we can find them and hear
them when they're foraging or grooming
at the surface of the water
the other thing that they will get are
flipper tags combination of two
flipper tags one on each flipper so that
we can visually identify them
when they're out in the water
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
visit the monterey bay aquarium's
website montereybayaquarium.org to learn
more about how you can donate
[Music]
you